RODERICK YAO: Hello everyone.
Welcome to my talk about
architecting and building
a data lake on GCP
with open source tools.
My name is Roderick Yao, I'm a
Cloud data engineer at Google
professional services.
We help our most
strategic customers
migrating to GCP and take
most advantage of GCP.
I work with many of the
customer across many industries,
from marketing,
retail, technology,
to financial services.
So Hadoop data lakes today
are the most common ones
that is on-prem.
So most of our [? in-price ?]
customer are moving Hadoop
to GCP, and the trend
is accelerating.
So today I'll walk you through
how to architect and build
data lakes on GCP and what
principles, tools, and patterns
that you should choose
to build data lakes.
On top of that, it
is important to know
how to secure and
govern a data lake.
So why should I run
data lakes on GCP?
So there are many
challenges that
gain value out of the
on-premise data lakes today.
The total cost of ownership
is very high, higher
than expected.
There are many hidden costs.
It's hard to project.
It's hard to scale, although
Hadoop is also built
on the principle of scale.
Governance and the security
usually is an afterthought,
and management burdens
are high on the teams.
The admin teams are struggling
with many tasks such as tuning
or scaling or
resource allocation,
guiding the application
teams, et cetera, et cetera.
The list goes on.
So by moving data
lakes to Cloud,
you can extend
existing investments.
In on-premise environment,
the cluster size
is almost fixed tuned
for maximum capacity.
In Cloud, you have the chance
to optimize for the cost
by spinning up and down clusters
and configure them separately.
So also in the Cloud,
you can scale easily.
No more take months to
get the capacity you need.
By moving some of the work
to managed components,
it can help reduce workload
for your big data team
and let users focus on add
more values more directly.
By utilizing more integrated
tools and existing patterns,
enable democratization
and elect more teams
to get access to data
they need, and finally,
by running more workloads
on natively-build tools
and platform, your team
can develop things quicker
and requires less maintenance
and more connectives
through the GCP platform.
So let's talk
about how to design
and migrating data lakes to GCP.
Because we're talking about
mostly Hadoop data lakes
for an on-prem customer,
that's what we most guide
our customers for,
there are many tools
to choose from to
build a data lake.
For example, these are just the
data [? analytics ?] product
in GCP.
I will walk you through
how to choose and build
a data lake using
these tools and also
the tools of your
choice of course.
Our guiding principles here
are open, integrate, and safe.
So open tool, many open
source big data tools
add file formats out of the box,
avoiding lock-ins and creating
another silo.
We want to make
sure the data lake's
more connected to the
other tools and capacities
such as Apache Spark, Hive
TensorFlow, and various GCP ML
AI APIs, et cetera, et cetera.
The third is safe.
Safe to migrate
without having to make
risky decisions while getting
benefit from the Cloud.
A couple of key considerations
when you migrating
stuff when you're planning.
So be clear about your near
term and long term goals
and priorities.
For example, if your data center
lease is ending in two months,
your goal should probably
get your data center
or get your clusters out of
there as soon as possible
rather than making
significant architecture
changes along the way.
The best way to utilize GCP
is to choose the right tool
for the workload instead of
finding just the replacement
tool for every tool
you have today.
It is best to utilize GCS's
separate storage and compute.
This will enable you to use
more ephemeral [? cluster ?]
or another type of Cloud
storage pattern to lower cost,
improve performance,
and scale better.
Last is you need to rethink
about your operations.
You will use a bunch
of different types
of cluster and services.
The old on-premise
management tools
such as Apache and
[INAUDIBLE] just
wouldn't help in that case.
You want to make your
infrastructure and application
developments as code, so
your application teams
can deploy them because
they know it better.
Most of our customer choose
to use Apache Airflow or Cloud
Composer to run their platforms.
Airflow packages most
of the operations
that you need to interact with
the Cloud providers products
into a different
Airflow operators.
Too many cluster
creation and deletion
could result in higher overhead.
For example, jobs
could take a little bit
longer to get started
and then shut it down.
So pooling clusters together
and add a middle layer
to choose a less utilized
cluster is a good idea.
There are some tools out there.
For example, Spotify creates an
open source tool called Spydra.
It's available on GitHub.
So let's take a look at the
usual workload patterns.
We generally have these
four types of workload.
It is best to know what type of
workloads that you're running.
So these profiles
and patterns will
help you choose which GCP tool
to use and what type of cluster
to run and how you should
implement security and data
governance.
So this part is very important.
So I like to discuss
technology choices
into these five different
layers of a data lake.
So let's start with the storage.
The main storage for a data lake
is the Google Cloud Storage.
It has many features
listed over here.
The most important ones are
it has immediate consistency.
One file as an object has
[INAUDIBLE] in through GCS
is mailed immediately,
available for listing.
So this part is
very, very important
for many Hadoop and
Spark workloads.
It helps facilitate many
transient or ephemeral clusters
by separate the
storage and compute.
There's no need for three times
replication such as in HDFS,
and you only need to
pay for what you use.
A little bit more
on GCS connector.
It's designed to support
Hadoop ecosystem workload
and working with GCS.
It's transparent to
use as a application,
so you can use whatever
format that you have.
It has improved support
for Parquet file
format for analytic workloads.
We can simulate atomic
directory operations
using cooperative locking.
So there's a little bit
more technical details
in the block here below.
So the best practice
for renting a storage.
So small files has
some problem for HDFS.
It creates a pressure
for name nodes.
Before GCS, too many
small files were
resolved like too many round
trips through the network,
so that adds up latency.
Always use the new
version of connectors
to take advantage of
the new improvements.
We're making them constantly.
Align your Parquet file
block size to 2 megabytes
because that's what the
GCS block size defaults to.
Always partition your data
to gain full-term benefits.
And regarding the
migration, the CRC checksum
are calculated differently
for HDFS and GCS
for the same object.
So we applied some
changes to that
to help you establish checksums.
In order to use those, so make
sure to use a Hadoop version
that's newer than 2.9.
If you don't have the
ability to upgrade,
cluster to a newer version.
You can choose a
workaround which
uses MD5 checksum to move to
a Dataproc cluster with HDFS
first.
Then move those files to GCS.
Regarding the
migration tools, DistCp
is the easiest way to
move data into GCS.
If you have HBase or
Cassandra in your cluster,
you can consider move
them to Cloud BigTable.
BigTable is a managed service.
It provides you
managed replication.
It's really easy to scale up.
It's fully compatible
with HBase APIs.
It has a nice data for templates
to help you to uploading.
One of the exceptions.
If you're using Apache
Phoenix, the data model,
it's actually similar to a Cloud
Spanner than Cloud BigTable.
So you can consider
move your data there
if you want to use a
managed tool for it.
If you only use Hadoop for
data warehouse use cases
and dealing with
only structured data
where it's a little bit
more semi-structured data,
you can consider
implement your data lakes
using BigQuery plus
BigQuery storage.
BigQuery storage API really
treats data warehouse
like a storage, and allow you
to use BigQuery like a data
warehouse plus a data lake.
So it integrates well with
many, many tools in GCP
and also open source ecosystem,
such as Apache Spark,
Hive TensorFlow and many
of the Cloud AI products.
So next part, we talk
about the Metastore.
Hive Metastore is a service
that stores metadata
about time tables like
schema and location
and partitions in the
relational database.
It's actually the
de-facto standard
for many of the SQL
engines on Hadoop
and also the newer trend
table formats such as Delta
Lake, Apache Iceberg,
and Apache Hudi.
Having the centralized Hive
Metastore with data on GCS
enable separate storage
and computes further.
You can use multiple cluster
operate on different Hive
tables simultaneously.
We just announced the alpha
of Dataproc Metastore.
It's actually a
managed Hive Metastore.
You can refer to
the talk about that.
So you can also map
your BigQuery tables
into Hive Metastore.
So you can use
something like this
and use a Spark BigQuery
connector to read data
from BigQuery.
Next, it's about
ingestion later.
Many of you are using maybe
Apache Flume, Apache Scoop
or third-party tools for
free ingesting data into GCP.
Google actually offers a
fully managed open source
tool called Data Fusion.
It's based on the
[INAUDIBLE] app.
It's a fully managed code-free
data ingestion service
for building and
managing data pipelines.
It has pretty deep
GCP integrations
with many type of
sources and syncs.
If you prefer, you
can still continue
to use Apache Flume and
Scoop together with Dataproc,
and it will also supports
many of the third-party tools
like Talon or Infomatica.
Next part about
processing layer.
This is mostly based
on your team's skills.
You can choose from one of
these two processing frameworks.
So Dataproc is the
managed Hadoop framework,
so it has many of the open
source data processing
firmware such as Spark,
Flink, Hive, Pig, and et
cetera, et cetera.
Dataflow is a service
framework using Apache Beam,
so it's a different programming
paradigm over there.
So the best practice of
choosing a processing framework.
When migrating, make
sure you at least
recompile your
application because you
want to match the Java version,
Spark, and Scala version
to the Dataproc image
version that you have.
For example, Dataproc 1.5 uses
Scala 2.12 version of Spark.
So it's maybe different
than the one you're using.
So at least recompile your
application to validate that.
When you deploy an
application on Dataproc,
autoscaling is good when you
don't know the exact size
of the cluster that you need.
But if you do know the job that
will need more than x number
of nodes, then start with that.
Don't just start with
the autoscaling from one
node cluster.
It will take very long
time to get there.
It has flexibility modes.
Allow you to store
shuffled data on HDFS
as a primer of workloads to
avoid job failures and restarts
when some of the nodes fail.
You might want to
consider use that.
E2 VMs and preemptible VMs are
great for drive down the cost.
But for preempted VMs, you're
having a risk of job failure
or lose progress when the
preempted Vms goes away.
Dataproc jobs API provides
authorization, authentication,
and auditing for jobs.
So you can consider using that
for submitting jobs to cluster.
Next, we can talk about
the data warehouse choice.
Native GCP data
warehouse is BigQuery.
But you can always
run open source query
engines such as Hive, Presto,
and others on Dataproc.
Customer found the best value
after migrating data warehouse
to BigQuery, where you implement
self-service data warehouse.
BigQuery requires no operation.
It is fully managed with
flexible resource allocation
and pricing model.
It supports multiple
file formats
that you can find and be able
to query them and ingest them
into BigQuery.
So when migrating a database
to BigQuery, in many case,
we scope a BigQuery
migration proof of concept,
even if the first
stage of migration
is a [INAUDIBLE] shift, just
to demonstrate the values.
The difference between the
existing data warehouse
and BigQuery may sounds
big at the beginning,
but for processing and
reporting of structure data,
most of our customer found
great value after PoC
and roll out more users
within two or three
months, sometimes just in a
matter of four to five weeks.
So what makes the migration
to BigQuery simple?
Migration is not just migrating
the storage and the engine
alone, it also is not
done until upstream
and downstream
pipeline components
are identified
and also migrated.
So a move to BigQuery
is easy for most people
because the connector exists for
very simple usage such as Spark
and BigQuery connectors, Hive
BigQuery storage handlers.
For downstream
consumptions, BigQuery
supports most of the BI
tools by JDBC and ODBC.
For many, BigQuery just simpler
and better user experience.
We'll see how the security and
data governance in the next few
slides.
Typically, you need
Kerberos and Ranger
to confidently secure Hadoop
data lake or data warehouse.
For BigQuery, it's all built in
and integrated with IM already.
Couple of the best
practices when migrating.
BigQuery supports data and
integer range partitioning.
It supports clustering
multiple columns.
However, this is
different than Hive.
So if your Hive table
is not partitioned
by data or through a range, you
want to repartition and load
the data to BigQuery.
Normally, you can [INAUDIBLE]
performance anyway just to
be sure.
BigQuery uses
standard [? NC ?] SQL.
There will be some
minor differences
for some of the functions.
But largely, it is compatible
with most of the query.
But like above, you can also--
if your Hive uses complex
partitioning strategy,
you may need to change
those queries as well.
The last, if you used to
run high ETL [INAUDIBLE]
of our scale and you also
liked BigQuery to do ETL,
it's better to do that
in the dedicated project
or dedicated slots,
allocated pool,
than using the same project
or the same [? slots ?] that
serves ad hoc queries just
to ensure a better user
experience.
So we have some
customers who want
to keep their data on-premise
and in other clouds
while also using GCP.
And they also want to use
one query engine and one
sets of a script to avoid
lock-ins or just create
another silos.
In this case, you can
actually use Presto for this.
It is easy to deploy
Presto on Dataproc
with the BigQuery connectors.
Naturally the connectors
use the BigQuery storage
API to provide
faster query results.
Presto has many other connects
through to talk to your,
for example, transactional
data warehouse,
your other enterprise
even legacy Hadoop clusters.
So next, I want to touch on
security and data governance.
There are many types
of identities in GCP.
You're familiar with
Google Identity.
That's when you sign in.
There are service accounts that
represents the application.
Let's see how that
impacts security here.
In a simple setup, in
this case, each user
has a distinct service account.
That person has a cluster use
his and her service account.
These cluster have data inside
GCS they need access to.
So from GCS access log
perspective, only service
accounts access the GCS.
But you can look it
up who actually did it
because the users and
service account has mapping.
Access control is only
on the bucket level,
so you could use a conditional
IM to fine tune that.
If you use jobs API,
you could find out
which user actually submitted
jobs through the login,
but more on that later.
In this setup with Kerberos,
we're using a shared cluster.
We want to make sure
user A is who they are.
So users [? are ?]
indicated via Kerberos,
so we can stop people from
using the service that they
don't have access to.
In the background,
all the API calls
are made by a service
account of that cluster.
So Dataproc with Kerberos will
setup KDC on the master node,
and KDC uses one-way
trust, or cross-room trust
to active directory.
If user SSH to the cluster,
they will use their Linux user
to interact with
Hadoop services.
Before they do that, they need a
kinit to get a Kerberos ticket.
So when they access outside
of a Dataproc cluster,
it's actually using
the service account.
BI tools in this case, if
you're not using BigQuery,
they will need to gain access
to the Hive or Presto port.
To be able to--
all the data acts
as human identity.
Previously, we talked about
from the access log perspective,
it is the service account
who access the GCS.
We develop a source
token broker,
and we presented last
year in the Cloud Next.
It will translate Kerberos
principal to Google Identity
and call GCP APIs using that.
So now you can control GCS data
for individual user access.
And the access control
is still on the bucket
level with the
conditional IM possible.
If you want a table-level
access control,
then you need to
use Apache Ranger.
So for authorization
management on data lake,
let's take a look
at what capabilities
are available in GCP.
On file system level, on-premise
HDFS uses POSIX permissions.
You can continue to use
that for HDFS on GCP,
but the HDFS comes
with the Dataproc only
for temporary storage.
So it's more important to
look at GCS access control.
For now, GCS only has
bucket-level access control.
Like I said earlier,
conditional IMs
are available with
prefix settings,
but the purpose is now really
just to do fine grain access
control to each object level.
So there's a limited number
of conditions you can apply.
On the SQL engine side,
on-premise, we usually
use Apache Ranger for
restricting a certain user,
tables, or columns.
On GCP, you can
continue to use Ranger
if you want to continue
to use open source SQL
engines such as Hive
and Presto, et cetera.
If you migrate your enterprise
data warehouse to BigQuery,
BigQuery natively
provide access control
on data set level, table level,
column level, and roll level.
These couple of
the later features
are available in beta right now.
Another level of access control
is service access control.
For example, which
Hadoop service or UI
the user can access to.
This is typically done by
either Hue or use Apache Knox.
On Dataproc, you can use
Apache Knox gateway to do that.
So first, let's take a look
at how Dataproc jobs API
can solve these authorization
problem to some extent.
While user A has
submit a job, logs
will show who actually
submit the job,
and GCS will still
show it's a service
account that access the data.
However, external BI application
doesn't really speak jobs API,
so they can only connect
to the unsecured connection
to the cluster.
So in a more complicated
setup with Ranger lets
you see how Ranger solved
the granular access control.
So Ranger can be started as
a Dataproc optional component
to use in the large
production system.
You might want to consider
centralized Ranger service
so it can be deployed
on GCE with a Cloud SQL
as the backend database.
Ranger provides database table
column-level access control
for HiveServer2.
Any request that goes
through HiveServer2
will be checked and
authorized by Ranger.
This will apply to BI tools
that connect through Hive.
Hive also has
plugin with Presto.
So the same thing if you--
BI to connect to this Presto,
Ranger can also solve that.
Ranger does not sync
permission to Cloud storage
like it did for HDFS.
To avoid this
issue, you can have
a cluster that only provides
SQL service with Ranger
to secure access so people
don't circumvent that.
As mentioned before, Apache
Knox can help control service
access such as allow and denying
access to YARN UI or Hue UI
would be something else.
It adds access control for
a cluster used by BI tools
instead of letting BI tool to
connect to the ports of Hive
or Presto or something else.
It passes user identity
to the cluster,
so Ranger can also apply
user-base authentication
and authorization
even without Kerberos.
Next, we talk about
metadata management tasks.
To make things work together
with open source big data
tools, there are
some solutions here.
GCP offers data catalog,
which catalogs data
from BigQuery Pub/Sub natively.
It also has a set of connector
to import catalog data
from Hive Metastore
and other systems.
Data Fusion provides a way of
standardized data processing
with native tools,
provided data lineage.
For open source
component, Apache Atlas
can provide those sort
of lineage from that.
Apache Atlas and their
catalog both provides a way
to tap and search your data,
automatically categorize
data, and match them more
crucial to processing
sensitive data.
So Google's data loss
prevention API and Apache Atlas
both provide a way
to categorize data
and match them when necessary.
So more on Apache Atlas.
It provides data lineage,
classification access
control working together
with Apache Ranger,
and also discovery capabilities.
It work with most open
source components.
It also has integration with the
third-party tool like Collibra.
So here's a way how you can
quickly create a new cluster
to test out the Apache
Atlas without affecting
other workloads.
So some of the
best practices when
we come to security
and data governance.
Application has
predefined behavior,
so these are usually informal
batch or streaming workloads.
They could be long running
or they could be scheduled.
These are not ad
hoc jobs, so there's
no really human
interaction in them.
So normally, we can
trust them running
and grant the minimum permission
to the service account
they're running, so you know
how to trace back to them.
For data warehouse, it
is mostly ad hoc queries
for these use cases.
Most user would just
send simple queries
through Hive and
[INAUDIBLE] others.
We recommended using
BigQuery to simplify this.
But if you do need to
run open source data
warehouse such as
Hive or Presto,
you can just use
Ranger to secure that.
For a third type, which we
call exploratory workloads,
they're specialized.
Maybe a data scientists
use PySpark to profile data
and build a model.
You can set up Dataproc cluster
with distributed notebooks
for the personal clusters
or team clusters,
provided you can control
access of fast service account.
If that doesn't
fit, say you want
to share the cluster
with a few more people,
then you can use Kerberos
together with open source
token book [? here. ?]
So let's talk a little
about hybrid and multi-Cloud
scenarios because I hear
this more often these days.
If you really think about
it, hybrid scenarios
are pretty common.
So every data migration
has a hybrid stage
where some of our data on jobs
are migrated, some are not.
To accommodate this
scenario, first you
need to have very
good interconnect
because you need to move data
or jobs through both environment
all the time.
Full DNS resolution,
it's important
if bi-directional
communication is needed,
and it's crucial for
Kerberos to work too.
And then, use a very
powerful orchestration tool,
like Apache Airflow or
Composer, to launch tasks
in all these different
environments.
Our customer typically
elect to choose
one tool to control all
the environment and people
to [INAUDIBLE] to
all the environments.
So make sure you have a
discovery service that
routes the workload to
the correct cluster based
on the request.
If you don't feel like
making copies of data
to different environments,
some other zero copy solution
like Alluxio could be
a good fit for that.
OK, so that concludes my talk.
To recap, we went through
high-level migration principles
of open, integrated, and safe.
Rules of migration, such as
establish clear priorities,
timeline, separating
storage and compute,
and rethink about operations.
Then we dive into the
tech stack choice.
We talk about storage choice
of GCS, BigQuery storage,
and Cloud BigTable.
Data Fusion for ingestions,
Dataproc and Dataflow
for processing layer.
For data warehouse
layer, we discuss
a choice of Hive,
Presto, and BigQuery
and what impact to consider
when moving them to BigQuery
and how to solve federated
environment query challenge
with Dataproc and Presto.
And then we talked about how to
secure and govern data lakes.
We talked about Kerberos
authentications,
what's the impact on
data access and auditing,
how to authorize data
using Kerberos Ranger, jobs
API, and Apache Knox.
BigQuery actually
does very good job
with solving those access
control challenges.
So definitely it's
a preferred way
of running data
warehouse on GCP.
Last, we discuss Apache
Atlas and data catalog
for data governance tasks.
So that's pretty much it.
Thanks for joining my talk.